do you think G and Russia think they can
succeed in negotiations with Biden more
than they would would Trump more than
they would with Obama or somebody knew
like a DeSantis
I think what they feel with Biden is
that it's it's a known quantity right
and I think that's I don't know whether
they feel that would be speculation my
part you know what you know how do they
berate them in in regards to who they
can negotiate with better but I do think
that they feel as if Trump is is more of
an unknown quantity uh and they can't
really
you know look and come up with like a
three to five year plan of what did you
want to keep it Biden in office
if you know if you know that guy is an
unknown quantity because he's not
predictable
if that is what you assess it assess it
to be you almost want to keep this guy
in office for another six years don't
you well based on look if if all you're
looking at is sort of a decision between
Biden and Trump and you look at Trump's
time in office and you look at Biden's
time in office if I'm a you know a head
of a Nation that's uh at odds with the
U.S I would prefer Biden because I can I
can more accurately predict I think in
my opinion where he's going to go what
his policies are going to be how he's
going to behave right and so yes I mean
I think there's you could you could make
that argument uh Trump was unpredictable
right and that's one of the reasons why
he lost the election people were tired
of the chaos right and but I think with
I mean Biden's been in DC for what 50 50
plus years yeah right you know you know
for me for me I wonder because
anytime a company has a CEO that didn't
want to communicate or I couldn't even
get a sit down with them I didn't I
didn't like that which means I couldn't
get things done I I would much prefer an
that was willing to sit with me
then somebody that was the nicest guy
would never call back never email and
never had time to come and sit down and
visit it's as weird as that sounds yeah
because you know at least the
you know you know what his agenda was
it's his company right against yours
it's his protection but the other guy
would you know was so like aloof and you
had to be very careful with the guys
that were very aloof okay so I wonder if
they sit there and they say you know
because let's put the blame on Russia
let's say Russia's behind this thing
because if Russia is using Israel and
South Korea
it's a form of dividing and conquering
you're pinning Israel against U.S and so
it's very strategic and Brilliant if
that's really what you're doing and to
be so good you also through some of your
internal stuff of Russia to make sure
people don't think you're the one that's
doing it which if you look at it is
absolutely minimal right right it's not
a big deal on their own right oh my God
yeah yeah but that's it's it's again
it's no question about it but but it is
very if let's just say if it is Russia
right then then if they're doing that to
pin Biden against uh uh uh Israel and
South Korea and then maybe they're
saying you know what this Trump guy at
least you know when he was there NATO
was not bothering us he was not a fan of
NATO we're not a fan of NATO you know
yes the trade issues was it is what it
is and we have to deal with that Huawei
we have to deal with that you know I
could never attack Ukraine under him so
do I really want this guy back I can
attack Ukraine under Biden but at the
same time if Trump was here and if I
attack Ukraine under Biden would they
have sent 140 billion dollars to Ukraine
to help would Trump have sent money I
don't know if Trump would have sent
money but maybe Trump would have had a
meeting with me within 24 hours to say
if you don't stop doing this then yeah
so I because to these guys the way I'm
processing it who do you want at the
helm do you want the guy that you can
have in the captain he kept conversation
and negotiate or do you want the guy
that is you know having worried about
the ice cream he's gonna have and you
don't really know if you can have a real
conversation that's my biggest thing who
do you want as an enemy sometimes I want
the leader of the enemy to be somebody I
can talk to no matter how much I may not
like the guy and how much we disagree
yeah yeah I I that's it's a an odd thing
here in the US I think maybe it's
elsewhere but this idea that you have to
like the person in charge right I don't
you know I didn't like Trump I don't
like Trump necessarily I think he's just
too chaotic and I think he's you know
he's all over the map I liked the
policies right I liked the policies
better yeah uh I don't need to like the
person necessarily I'm more interested
in what are they doing you know as as a
leader so but with you know Putin I I'm
sure you know Putin looked at at Biden
and he remembered it was Obama Biden
when they you know walked into Crimea
and there was no response right they
took Crimea and and during that
Administration and you know there was no
pushback really to speak of and so they
probably factor that into their
calculation over Ukraine I I'm sure
Putin was surprised at the at the my
monetary response sort of the way the
Allies came together and said because I
I figure that calculation was probably
different they probably thought the U.S
will not get quite so involved they will
not make quite the effort with NATO but
um I I you know to that degree his
intelligence was was clearly off but um
yeah I I agree with you I think you know
if I'm
if I'm looking at this and I certainly
if I'm G if I'm G and I think that I'm
close to the top of the of the of the
ladder here uh I would much rather have
somebody like President Biden in place
because again I can look at him and I
think I can I can map out and predict
based on that 50 plus years where he's
going if that's the case I won't do this
because this hurts that's the only thing
so if I'm sitting here thinking about
you're doing this I wouldn't do this
because you're hurting the existing guy
because you're giving more ammunition to
the opposing side I I would I would let
it roll rather than doing this to say
hey because do you remember when Trump
had to keep firing people in CNN CNN and
MSNBC would constantly say there's a uh
uh Source within Trump Administration
what a terrible thing to do to a guy to
confuse a crap out of him like think
about when they say there's a player
within the New England Patriots
organizations that's leaking information
to us at ESPN that there's a major fight
and have fallen out between Tom Brady
and Bill like those types of things and
your Brady and Belichick you're like hey
guys stop it we're good we don't have it
but then in the back your mind you're
like who's talking is it that guy
that I binged is it that guy that I
didn't let do this because that guy that
I didn't invite to the part is it that
guy that wants to be traded what is it
regardless of how much bulletproof
strong mentally tough you are they get a
little bit of your brain and you start
thinking so regardless no matter how
bulletproof this Administration may be
they're going to say who at the Pentagon
wants Republican Trump to be there
that's not on our side we got to fire
this person who is that person it's a
general this it's a general is it this
person
this this this really throws a wrench in
the game yeah that's all I'm saying so I
don't know yeah I mean again it's it's
speculation at this point obviously you
know to say that you know it could it be
uh a uh covert action campaign by the
Russians but I'm saying that when you do
something like this when you're
investigating somebody this you have to
keep all the options on the table until
you approve otherwise and you know
that's it's and again I I would argue
that they they already know if they
don't already know what's going on with
this then that is really disappointing
yeah if if you're doing it at the KGB
level of Putin trust me Putin's got like
a board of I would assume he's got a
board of everybody who to poke to piss
off with who and create a proxy here to
unify here so we can become the good guy
and call these guys and do a favor for
that guy so he can connect us with this
guy and get in front of I mean I'm
assuming that's how these rooms these
conversations are going to be had so
yeah then it's election time you got
eight more months left nine more months
left before we decide who the Republican
candidate is going to be so the Santa's
Trump you know who do you want to be the
head if you are really meddling in
elections I would be really more thought
out of who I'd want to eliminate to
create the enemy against so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]